nous sommes à montrouge en banlieue
parisienne dans ce lycée les terminales
viennent d'avoir les réponses à leurs
demandes d'orientation sur parcours sup
et les résultats sont loin bien loin de
leurs espoirs et de leurs attentes
j'ai que des noms tels samoa samoa
choque un peu quand j'ai vu que j'avais
pas de bonnes notes que c'est mon
dossier de première gd que des attentes
genre d oui mais oui si des places se
libèrent ya jamais eu de réponse précise
t elle dans les yeux en attente
malheureusement je me dis qu'on va se
trouver là si j'ai pas d'école et ben je
trouve que je travaille plus je
travaille pas j'ai fait du tout je vais
passer mon bac ne sachant pas ces genres
et une école après ce concours est
mais ça sert à quoi parce que mon
travail mais
même pas d'école en fait c'est ça sert à
quoi on fait tout ça pour peut-être rien
au final 1 cette angoisse de se
retrouver sans solution et très
récurrente tout comme un sentiment
d'injustice sociale
ces élèves sont souvent convaincus que
venir d'un lycée de banlieue dessert
leur dossier en quelqu'un qui vient de
paris 15 par exemple sera plus
facilement accéder que quelqu'un qu'il
ya de montrouge hauts-de-seine morigène
mois sachant que
c'est les classes et pas les plus
faciles les comportements c'est alors
qu'ils d'exemplaires des notes c'est pas
forcément les meilleurs et du coup voilà
mais ça restait pas forcément notre
niveau d'intelligence ou notre niveau de
facultés à apprendre et de compréhension
quand je vois ce qu'ils sont marie curie
par exemple y avait tout le monde n'est
pas pris un bien sûr mais il y en a
beaucoup plus qu'ils sont pris ils ont
des meilleurs dossiers
enfin c'est pas juste pour les ondes des
meilleurs dossiers parce qu'ils viennent
d'en réaliser différents quoi et c'est
pas forcément le niveau qui en ressort
est c'est hallucinant devant ce qui
ressemble un début d'incendié
la ministre frédéric vidal tente de
calmer le jeu et demande de la patience
les lycéens qui auront des propositions
en accepterons certaines en refuseront
d'autres et donc libéreront des places
et on s'attend à ce que de manière
dynamique il est plusieurs centaines de
milliers de places qu'ils soient libérés
le 26 juin une phase dite complémentaire
de parcours sub sera lancée les lycéens
pourrons alors formuler une nouvelle
liste de voeux